nice feet inside da clock winding down
engrams on the pull-up contested shop
cornet right in his face and he nails it
holiday holiday beautiful class the lead
for Ingram took a shot to the head as we
put it down they've got a budding star
when Williamson comes back all cemented
around the leadership good luck once
again for George cool JJ Redick with
Ingram spacing he's going to the line on
the five hakurei's ninth assist to
draymond Green with six points nine
assists and two incredible
that's like Plastic Man
series wakes man yeah that is impressive
so anchor boy to the free-throw line
he leads the bells with 40 count the
times that the team got to the other
three-point line he dunks this with 20
seconds that's the four seconds on the
bowels kintyre take a lead they had one
leave already
now it's tied at 14 Kenny Atkinson calls
the timeout very well don't we from
Baton Rouge Ingram inside that is a
patient heavy because of his size and
his ability to get where he wants to get
on the floor and excellent use and
patience of the pump fake right there
got out of high position force a lot do
they know very efficient drew Albany the
sighs Brandon Ingram all the way Bob get
to the foul line and this three-point
shot as well this is what takes you to
another level or physical so I go back
and I watch that paper and you know it
was really impressive about Ingram
Alexander Walker slapped away two years
for coaches his health at Michigan State
he had some space on the art what about
Derrick Favors on the finish this in
getting a defensive stop being there
early and often to take that shot inside
a tenth of the shot clock monk blocked
away Derrick Favors
he was defending to that time with P
ombo on the cut with the hammer
and one of the keys to start the game
was using your defense and allowing that
to start to office Derrick Favors
in the passing lane favors has been very
active and favors on the pit crew
holiday size ended up bankrupt for three
got it
six-point lead for the palace we plus
two black sea 29 points backdoor lob not
even close by Rodney hood now Williams
running in the floor nobody's not the
basketball
[Applause]
Terry supports the timeout give Bandhan
Ingram back on the floor because these
plays would miss the last four games
Phoenix Suns with the number eight rated
off every shot right there inside by
Brandon Ingram with that long reach
Devin Booker Holliday defending here
comes Tyler Johnson inside we kept it
inside beautifully by Ingram attention
ten on the shot clock
play To Your Strengths he's got the legs
it's a tough ball away
makes no difference over a neighborhood
precent pounds back even thirteen early
lighten it up 23 per Mitchell Ingram
posting up O'Neal wonderful the chair
down the difficult all the way yes so
again the bells come all the way back
same trail turn the corner no one's
there no Rudy Gobert you continue to
attack the rim it's round pick a couple
of years ago 21st overall granted a
group right by Gallinari before that
hesitation frozen ended what's your good
bells get out of the break size
advantage Brandon Ingram on Terrence
Ferguson step through smart boo he can
get this every time there's no one on
the floor for gotta go guard Brandon
Inge no one that can guard Brandon
Ingram right now and he knows that about
the 4 for 21 performance that he had
against the Lakers and he is aggressive
tonight I love it when you collapse the
team's defense there's nothing bad that
can come from it the same page
breakpoints are 22 2
Brandon Ingram takes a contested three
and gets it right athletic and he hasn't
even started to play now lost by Don
Jaques and they don't turn the ball over
a lot
it'll be JJ Redick inside the arc and
the first 30% on the season and making
15 goodness with the thing they need to
know about what it is to be a
professional and if there's a silver
lining to all of the injuries it's been
that young guys have gotten a chance to
completely control the shopbot a triple
yes down to six inside of seven to play
guards have to do their job as far as
individual ball containment it's
concerned as well Brandon Ingram
[Applause]
Ahn's on TV boys for almost 50 years now
and he is just he loves me
[Music]
put it this way it was a not a
traditional dung put it that way no one
a traditional because he jumping over
dude get six foot ten to 80
I like the that's impressive that is
impressive
Khalil Okafor also a three Ingram on a
switch got Griffin a deep triple yes
[Applause]
it will
[Applause]
he's slowing down
[Applause]
[Applause]
Derrick Favors need some help now six of
the shot clock
Brandon a rising for a triple
by 11 he's a good fit for this team
Bogdanovich deny frighteningly takes it
away held up by Bogdanovich on the trail
JJ takes his time way back one in 2011
[Applause]
maxima left
Clarkson's in Gobert was running a
finger roll and as opposed to Alonso
going 101 he kicks it up and gives so he
just barely touched that other one on
its way down plenty of time
spins it up and it's out Ingram to
rebound Rudi has not had a rebound since
the first quarter for yet yeah slices
dices
dhingra's might slip past favors that
just beautifully
Ingram fakes now on the pull-up got it
Butler Brandon Ingram continues his role
a fierce what a breakout season Brandon
Ingram has had seven of pot from the
field he's got 17 and the pelicans six
point lead after two quarters here at
the garden
[Music]
whatever they wanted meant something
guys got a decent handle boy does he now
Ingram at the buzzer
yeah seen that before Nathan the league
in rebounding blurs it away actually
third the lake at fifteen fourteen and a
half force a game blocks away but he
took a shot to the back as he went into
the statute whist didn't think that was
a smart play from behind it look like
[Applause]
for the Australian fire the relief
effort in Australia Ingram on the run
[Applause]
Ingram top against O'Neal they'll get it
to Brandon Brandon with two on the clock
for the win
[Applause]
what are we saying the beginning of the
game because the way they do top 10
cards that pick and roll Brandon Ingram
understands you can print so Naomi you
can put back down to filming you can put
Joe labels on me I can feel an elevator
love of a step back one Bruin against
another a good job I drew holiday will
sit out it's a good job by throughout
the day that's what he does
now Ingram corner three filling it up
bells by four eight on the shot clock so
clear out nine so Paul yeah he knows
seven of nine four four from beyond the
arc good right now he should be the
free-throw line
good luck Brandon Ingram wanted to go
inside he will it'll be Zion what the
adjustment
it's always fascinating to me to watch
Redick just move just track his
movements on either side hanker a little
reverse finish by Brandon Ingram who
really dig deep into the playoffs he's
it he's a guy that she can put in
multiple spots on the court
ain't grunt little turnaround is good
he's got that in his bag as well Brandon
Ingram he slimed well when you're long
and athletic and you have a small guard
on you it's a matter of this creating
the space and getting to the Senate and
not being rung for the bells caught him
by surprise got Josh Hart
Ingram off the dribble heat inside the
perfect passive Williamson another dunk
Terry stops once timeout a sign of great
improvement by a natural scorer the
secondary ball handler the way the ball
moves see Danny Green coming back on the
floor the first quarter counted and then
Ingram that time it just kind of lost
out of his hands he his hand did come
off of the ball it didn't stay connected
so if they don't call it it's not a foul
is not it but it's a basket for Ingram
Josh are hampered he'll get it Nance Jr
we know about him and the boards he's
got Ingram in his sights
[Applause]
in rhythm points of the Laker game and
it's hard to beat a really good team
when you turn into basketball over at
that clip it just goes to whatever just
seven that soundbite Brin having to get
through multiple defenders one of whom
is Dwight Howard I mean that's a
big-time move here's a group for three
over green it's gone including this
three pointers look at that release
point like dams Green is a very good
defender but that that close is slow and
Lonzo just told him right now that's my
bad right that's my bad
second turnover for the Pels we're even
as nine take it away
jump that dribble handoff and points off
the takeaway good work guards to Brandon
Ingram let's apply his game you want to
know where he is you can find them at
the practice facility great
concentration as Courtney Lee gets into
his landing area he's shooting a
career-high gives it up Malone cheese
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content